we're featuring my interview with
traditional Polynesian ocean Voyager 9
OA Thompson and I had to ask him how the
ancient Polynesians navigated 2400 miles
from Hawaii to Tahiti without being able
to calculate longitude let's check it
out okay imagine imagine you're standing
on the beach at Waikiki you're looking
over the horizon to where ta t is and
then imagine you draw one line like I'm
like like an arc to the west side of TT
and the other I on to the east side
that's your target it's less than a
degree so your destination is not in
view because it's far beyond your life
so so your destination spans an angle
from where you're standing in Waikiki
and as long as you navigate inside that
angle nothing else matters right because
you're gonna get to your target on the
other side really really smart in fact
it seems to me your angle can be wider
than that because you just have to get
your destination within your horizon and
then you can just reckon to it
50 miles yeah yeah 15 miles so you have
a 30 mile so it's really the width of 30
miles at the distance of where you're
headed that's your angle 2,400 miles
away though is thirty oh yeah that's
that's narrow but still it's a known
problem right yes
so but there's so many unknowns in the
navigation that it's not it's not a GPS
it's not a coordinate system you don't
have longitude you need you need
instruments and you need tables which we
don't have it's a dead reckoning system
so you only know where you are but
memorizing where you come from if you
memorize or your complement you got to
be awake you know we stay up 21 22 hours
a day so it ain't easy here's what you
do
slip this in your so what that's that
same sex I see he didn't take it
[Laughter]
[Music]